façon les gens qui vont regarder ça
c'est des gens qui aiment bien le dessin
c'est pas forcément les gens comme le
sketch
[Musique]
je sais pas comment ça avec ce que tu
fais ça s'appelle je sais pas l'auto
promotion franchi fois qu un truc on va
dire chez pas que c'est vachement dur de
qualifier la taille dans un truc où on
t'attends pas un genre nos baskets que
tu crois au génie tu crois pas que c'est
le travail qui fait les choses bah comme
disait jacques brel ya pas de fumée sans
feu
attends je sais c'est nul parce que
j'étais une référence montre bien tu
peux dire toi méfier des gens qui
donnent de et pas de talent et que du
travail
ouais bah ouais moi je crois qu'avant on
croyait au génie parce que les gens se
rendaient pas compte de la technique il
n'avait pas la technique et maintenant
comme on est à peu près tous égalitaire
par la technique on a à peu près accès à
toutes les techniques du coup ce qui
fait la différence c'est le tas froid ça
c'est malin ça si tu m'écoutes ce divan
c'est le moins cher de chez fly de dos
on dirait que ses parents quand on
décide
c'est la gérante alors qu'est ce que tu
penses de bertrand cantat comme l'a
d'ailleurs dans chat perché est ce que
tu crois que je devrais faire un remake
jaune désire tellement d'art sétois
norman qui pend way we tous ces chats
dans paris qu'on voit partout c'est toi
donc bah ouais ça fait ça fait dix 10
ans le feuillage à moi je fais ces
dessins nul je l'appelle déjà dans la
vidéo c'est bon voici mon laisse à sanaa
un style ah mais non ce qui vient de se
passer totalement aberrant en plus le
rejet des films et regarde alors là si
c'est pas bon ça hardcore le canada est
resté basculer le cogne à montchat le
côté ça fait contrepoids merci mes chats
et aucun risque que tu bascules l'ours à
cergy
il est jaloux qui arracha
en titrant je loue un vélo je vais faire
un plan artistique
vivendi gagne et puis là qu'est ce qui
se passe ping c'est plus du tout acte
artistique est attachant ne sais pas je
ne suis pas du che aujourd'hui était
trop de la chance j'ai pas eu le temps
j'étais tellement année mais moi je suis
carrément que premier degré aaa
c'est-à-dire que je peux prendre des
cours de blogs avec toi parce que
choisit ni à ses côtés au premier degré
je commence à intégrer le 2ème 3ème de
leur valeur après je vais des degrés
trop trop lointain merci un conseil
allez à l'examen
[Musique]
il est très différent ça il a fumé et
tous les yeux rouges ni mal tu peux
rajouter avec une bombe
en plus j'ai eu une et croquettes cp des
croquettes qui devient sa des trucs là
des pâtés pour charles gimat diane lane
ils parlent pas français lui il parle
que allemand amer mais on a je suis dans
la merde à l'eau des quatre ceux d'un 6
nice qui reste cergy
[Musique]
et
lellouche
[Musique]